winter is coming and nothing's perfect
so I did my list of my favorite
characters on Game of Thrones both
living and dead you know what no matter
how good any show is there's always
gonna be some weak links I think I got
to address the worst characters to
appear on Game of Thrones now again keep
in mind I haven't read the books I'm
judging this only on the way in which
they are presented in the TV show it's
quite possible that some or all of these
characters are phenomenal in the book so
they just got whittled down to a version
that doesn't work on TV or maybe they
were miscast or anything else I don't
care I'm not taking that into account
now in discussing why I don't think
these characters work I am gonna have to
talk about various things that they have
done so consider that your spoiler
warning if you're not caught up through
the end of season 4 there may be stuff
you don't want to hear yet here we go
with number 10
Searcy Lannister I actually I feel
really bad having her on this list but
I've got too many issues with her and
I'm honestly I'm gonna break it down to
the writing because I think the
portrayal is quite good and I like how
strong she is and I feel there is depth
of nuance or but I feel like the writers
keep beating certain aspects of her
character over the head of the audience
I think the drinking is the big thing
they've really turned her into an epic
drunk since about season two it's so
rare to see her without a goblet of wine
in her hands and while I get that that's
an aspect of her character they just
won't let it go and it's just gotten so
much emphasis it's really annoyed the
heck out of me and then there was the
whole thing that went on with her and
Jamie in season 4 that just kind of
deflated her further because sort of the
main redeeming factor of her was just
her strength but then that thing
happened and appeared to happen the way
that it did and that she let it happen
and didn't take retribution for it
happening I it just softened her all the
more number nine mance rayder this is a
case where this is a guy who we've heard
so much about but seen so little of he's
well cast and thankfully they cast guy
who's got a certain amount of screen
presence and a certain amount of Menace
and he helps sell it as best as it can
be sold but it's just we spent so much
time hearing about him before we
saw him and then when we saw him and
then he vanished for so long and again
we keep hearing about him but everybody
talking about how dangerous or how
influential and somebody is as opposed
to actually showing us that that's a
problem and it just makes the character
not stick and not have the resonance
that he probably should have I mean he
should feel like a threat he should feel
like a pretty big problem honestly he
feels more like an annoyance that I wish
the show would just kind of wrap up and
deal with already so we can get on to
different stuff
number eight Daario naharis now this is
really a criticism of the recast Daario
naharis the original guy that they had
when he showed up in season 3 I actually
really liked cuz he was a little bit odd
it kind of in the same way that the
faceless assassin was on and that he
couldn't quite pin him down you're like
I think this is kind of your deal but I
was intrigued by him the recast version
of Dyer and the horrors I'm not
intrigued by I feel like I can read him
like a book and he's just been played
very much straight that he is enamored
with Daenerys when it the stuff was
going on in season 3 he was saying that
and you got that aspect it felt like
there was something else that I couldn't
quite pin down and I liked that and that
that now feels gone with the new guy and
I'm just gonna put that down to the
performance I just think that the guy
that they got to replace the original
actor just isn't bringing as many layers
to the character he's playing it
straight and played straight he's kind
of boring number seven Tommen Baratheon
this is just a case of he's a blank
cypher I probably would have completely
forgotten he was even a part of the show
if he had not been crowned king in the
fourth season now I get that he actually
is very unimportant and at this point
the show has actually done a pretty good
job of emphasizing the fact that
whoever's sitting on the Iron Throne it
doesn't really matter the problems go
out with the country and the kingdom are
much bigger than whose butt is sitting
on that throne so putting this sort of
nonentity like torment on the throne it
very much fits with that but at the same
time it feels weird in the wake of
Robert and then Joffrey and so many
people that were deep and interesting
and layered characters who were fighting
to be on the throne that now the guy
who's actually sitting on it is just
such a blank slate from from the overall
story I get why he's a blank slate cuz
it just it makes him much more easily
manipulated they looked for awhile
they're like Tywin was just gonna be
pulling every string and then Tommen was
just gonna be the face but obviously
time was now out of the picture so we
don't know who'll be pulling the strings
but it's very clear Tommen himself
doesn't have a lot going on and while
that is kind of fits with the story and
everything it makes him as a character
incredibly disposable number six Sansa
Stark now there was a time not that long
ago she probably would have been right
up at the top of this list close to
number one if not at it but what's going
on with her and towards the very end of
season four has me intrigued that she
may be turning around I'm actually
really interested to see what gets done
with her in season five now my hope for
her turning around though does not
change the fact that she has annoyed the
ever-loving hell out of me through
pretty much the first four seasons of
the show inside of what's been really
irritating and part of why even though
I'm hopeful she'll turn around I'm
nervous that she won't she had a couple
of other points earlier as like ooh
maybe she's gonna become interesting
here and then they just do something to
reverse that or cop out or whatever say
at the end of season one she had the
moment where she was about to push
Joffrey off that legend like ooh she's
got some guts to her but then in season
two she had no guts and she was just
Joffrey's whipping post and then later
when she gets married off to Tyrion they
start developing this interesting
relationship she starts to become
interesting again and then the red
wedding happens and she just goes right
back into sulk mode cuz her family's
dead but now we've got third shot
hopefully third time's the charm where
now she is very much in cahoots with
Petyr Baelish and maybe she's gonna be
going somewhere interesting but she's
just been so whiny sona she's been such
a wet blanket she's been and she's been
a pawn in so many things that she's
she's a commodity she just keeps getting
moved around and who controls her
changes but she herself has contributed
very little now that said if she
actually sort of takes hold of her own
destiny and has a sense of agency
herself going into the new season she
may finally
turn around but man it's been rough
getting there number five the mountain
now the mountain is impressive the
mountain is a badass I'm not gonna argue
any of that but he kind of suffers from
the same problem as mance rayder which
is that we've heard about him a heck of
a lot we have seen very very very little
of him he made a strong first impression
in that first season but then season 2
we saw him once season 3 we didn't see
him at all seized before he finally came
back but we basically had two and a half
seasons where everyone was talking about
the things he was doing and what a
badass he was and how dangerous he was
but we weren't seeing it so when he
showed up at the start of season 4 and
he's just levelling guys for the fun of
it it didn't have the impact that it
should have because we should have been
seeing what this guy was before that so
when Searcy goes up to him and says that
she wants him to be her champion that
should have been oh yeah but it didn't
quite have that impact because the
character that everyone's just been
talking about who we've seen so little
of again I get that there really weren't
that many places to fit him in and what
he was doing was very ancillary to the
main story but considering the the
ultimate payoff that ended up happening
with him you'd think they would have
planted at least a couple of bits here
and there to just remind us that he's
out there and what he's about as opposed
to just sort of dropping him almost
completely for two seasons then having a
comeback go remember how bad this guy
isn't like I guess I do
sure number four Robin Arryn now first
time we saw him in season one he was
actually quite amusing in a weird little
way this is a messed up kid clearly who
has no idea that he's messed up his
whole perception on the world is
completely warped and twisted by his
mother and his appearance in that first
season was pretty cool pretty nifty was
some fun stuff then when they brought
him back and now he's a little older and
still acting that same way oh man really
and now he's just grading and that's
always sort of the problem that you have
with a character who is basically there
to irritate and get on the nerves of the
other characters you know what he's got
to get on the nerves of the audience as
well thankfully we're not supposed to
sympathize with him but he's not grading
in the way that Joffrey was cuz Joffrey
you love to hate
Joffrey you really could get worked up
about I can't get worked up about Robyn
I'm just irritated by him he's just the
noise a little snot number three Lysa
Arryn pretty much same thing I said
about Robin she was good and
functionally slightly off her rocker
when she showed up in that first season
she shows up again and yoake same
schtick a couple years older got it the
reason I'm ranking lice a higher on this
list than I'm ranking Robin is because
as a child character I'll make certain
allowances for Robin being as shallow a
character as he is I mean he's young
he's obviously had a really weird
upbringing so he's got to be emotionally
stunted and not you sort of get social
cues and all of that Lysa on the other
hand she's an adult and once more she
was an adult who was in the court and
married to the hand of the king so while
I get that she's kind of nuts I feel
like she should have had a better sense
of how to function in society and she
seems almost as disconnected as her son
is but when an adult hasn't that same
thing going on it just it feels like
there should be more just behind that or
underneath it or informing it or layers
somewhere but she's just not she's crazy
it's it just it feels like kind of a cop
out on a show with so many deep and
layered characters she's just she's very
OneNote number two Shae man I gotta tell
you I was so glad when she got killed I
can't even begin to tell you now I get
why she's in there I get her function
and her purpose as a character
especially with how things alternately
paid off with Tyrion it was important
that she was there it was important that
she stuck around for as long as she did
but the problem was she really just took
a turn even before that she showed up in
that courtroom to testify against him
just everything she did you were going
Tyrion why are you still pining for this
woman
and again I I get it I understand it but
she just became such a burden so quickly
and then stayed that way for so long
yo initially she sort of challenged her
even a little bit obviously showed him
what appeared to be very genuine
affection that affected him and as an
audience member I was like okay fine but
then she got so whiny and became such a
just a brick around his neck almost
immediately and then just stayed that
way the entire time she was in King's
Landing she she did nothing to remind us
why Tyrion fell for her in the first
place or why as a nineties remember I
was at least okay if not and fully on
board with her but she just became the
burdensome girlfriend who does nothing
but add obstacles and add irritation and
add conflict into a show that does not
need pointless conflict it's got plenty
of meaningful conflict she just
irritated the hell out of me for so long
I can't not put her this high and our
top spot number one worst character
solis Baratheon now this may seem like
an odd pick cuz she actually hasn't done
a heck of a lot she's just kind of
appeared intermittently since season two
so you know why would I put her up here
because I can see where she's going and
that's something I can say about almost
none of the characters of the show even
the ones I don't like that's one of the
best things about this show you can't
predict where a character's going what's
gonna happen to them her I feel like
I've got her completely pegged now it's
possible the show will surprise me but I
don't think so because she's just she's
gonna be a problem I know she's gonna be
a problem nobody is that blindly
stupidly blinders or religiously fervent
as her who does not end up becoming a
problem in these types of stories
Stannis is gonna have a crisis of
conscience and she's gonna feel like
he's not properly representing the Lord
of Light she'll be a problem that way or
she'll declare McKeithen and get some
some sort of rival thing going in there
her own little army or whatever whatever
the problem is but her rigid and blind
devotion is going to make her a problem
and I know
that I saw that from the beginning and
it hasn't happened yet but I know it's
going to and it's just such a cliched
path in the first place cuz again we've
got plenty of religiously motivated
characters with layers and with death to
them like lady Melisandre like the
brothers without banners that having her
be this sort of almost Spanish
Inquisition kind of character just it
feels like a cop-out and it's so
simplified that it feels like it doesn't
belong in this universe of much deeper
much more layered characters I mean the
great things about the characters in
these show is that they've got many
motivations oftentimes conflicting you
know they've got their interest in power
but maybe they're conflicted because
they also want to protect their family
and maybe those are in conflict with
someone like Daenerys you have her
desire for conquest and revenge but at
the same time wishing to be a good and
noble ruler and those are coming into
conflict and to have someone who's just
so no it's this this is what I'm all
about
and that's it and just it it just is
such a ill fit for this world and for
all these deep characters that I just
wish she wasn't even there so there you
have it I love this show but these are
what I feel are the 10 worst characters
so who do you think is the worst
character on Game of Thrones I don't
care how big of a fan of this show you
are there's at least one out there that
you go I really don't like you and not
in that fun love to hate them Joffrey
Baratheon wait like you genuinely wish
they just weren't on the show whoever it
is drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it until next time
this council is adjourned